[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: Welcome, everybody.
Thank you for coming today.
Today we're here to talk
about a kind of combined
super-use case.
I'm trying to show one
possible end to end and use
that as a excuse to talk
about the compositing
of different pieces and tools
that are available to us
and the improvement of
the tooling landscape
around doing machine learning.
Firstly, I'd like to
thank Eli and Kunith
in particular for their help
in putting this together.
The code that we're going
to step through today
definitely had some challenges
and bumps along the way.
And we'll be talking through
some of those points as well.
And of course, the
Cloud developer
relations team, thanks to them
for their continued support
of this and other efforts
to engage with the community
and gather feedback.
Quick check-- can you
hear me OK on the mic?
Awesome.
We've got a little--
so yeah, it feels
like it's only sort
of picking me up sometimes.
So I'll try to shout
where possible as well.
OK, so we wanted to
show a couple of things.
And then we got a
couple more things.
And then the title
got really long.
And then we cut it down some.
And that's what we ended
up with, all right?
So it's a bit of a mouthful.
There's a lot of
things in there.
We really wanted to capture what
we were trying to show and not
leave anything out.
We ended up leaving a few
things out, but not everything.
So that's what we got.
But the title is
pretty descriptive.
You know, we're going
to go on Kaggle.
So who's heard of
Kaggle, Kaggle.com?
It's the data science
platform, community website.
You can run code on there.
There's the competitions.
There's forums.
And we're going to use
Keras on Kaggle, right?
And we're going to use the
GPUs that Kaggle has-- yes,
Kaggle also has free GPUs
to use, so that's fun--
and train up a model in Keras,
but then convert that model
and export it to be suitable
for running on Cloud ML Engine
so you can scale
your predictions
and serve them broadly.
And so that's a whole
kind of process.
And so hooking that entire
workflow up and then
actually calling that
endpoint, that REST endpoint,
with new, previously unseen
data, that end to end workflow
is kind of what we're
aiming to achieve today.
So we, in the
description, kind of said
that this could be viewed
as a pseudo-workshop.
I'll step through all the
code on screen as well.
But if you want to log in to
or create a Keggle account,
all you need is an email.
You can do that.
It's free, of course.
And if you already have or--
have a Cloud account set
up, you can get that ready.
At some point, there will
be a link to the code
that we'll be
playing with today.
So of course, this is a--
what did we call it-- not the
Cloud AI huddle, the Google AI
huddle.
AUDIENCE: That's right.
YUFENG GUO: And going into
this, for the most part,
I'm going to make some broad,
general assumptions around base
knowledge around
machine learning.
And so I'm just going to throw
this slide up here as kind
of a level set of saying my
short and sweet definition
of machine learning is basically
just programming with data,
more or less, right?
Like, if you strip away
as many details as you can
and try to make
something that's shorter
than the title of
this talk, this
is kind of what you end up with.
And our plan, in
more concrete detail,
around what we looked at
earlier is we'll grab the data.
And we'll talk about with
data set we're going to use.
Then we're going to do some
fiddling with the data.
Then we'll do some more
And then we'll create our model.
We'll do training
and evaluation.
Oftentimes, after
doing that, you
go back and have to
revisit the other steps.
And then there's
some work, right?
There's-- oh yes, and we should
turn on our GPUs at that point.
And we'll convert
that model from Keras
to a TensorFlow
Estimator, which can then
be exported to a SavedModel,
which can then be uploaded
to Google Cloud Storage.
Then we can create
a model version
on Machine Learning Engine.
And then we can
make a prediction.
So it's definitely a
long workflow, right?
And so this is
intentional in that I
wanted to highlight the
fact that, while there are
a lot of tools out
there, there are ways
to get them to fit together.
Some ways are
easier than others.
harder than others.
But increasingly, the
compatibility surface
between different tools,
different products
are growing every day.
And so I think, while we pass
through this phase where not
everything is going to be
super, super-duper easy,
you have to embrace multi--
different tools,
different environments,
and try, then, to get
them to fit together
even if you have to kind
of shave the corner off
of one piece to get it to
fit together with the other.
So the data set--
who has heard of
the MNIST data set?
Yes, so I figured we would
do something a little more
interesting than MNIST, but only
a little bit more interesting.
It's called EMNIST.
It's the extended
MNIST data set.
It comes to us from the
same National Institute
of Standards and Technology.
But we get some letters, right?
Better than just 10 digits,
we have some letters,
and not only lowercase,
but also uppercase letters.
Yeah.
But more notably is
the fact that we are--
it's predicting
across 47 classes.
And of course, the format
is also very similar.
It's still MNIST.
It's still 28 by 28
grayscale images.
So on one hand, it's still
that same sort of stuff.
But on the other
hand, it's something
less boring than 0, 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, and 9.
And moreover, the differences
between the capital letters
and lowercase letters can
make for some interesting
interactions, right?
And you'll notice that
there's only 11 letters that
are different enough, between
their upper and lowercase
representations, for
it to really count.
Like, the letter X is not going
to show up and make us figure
out, is this the lowercase X
or an uppercase X. Apparently
everyone's handwriting
is too bad for there
to any distinguishment.
So that's our data set.
Let's stop briefly about
libraries, all right?
We're going to use Keras today.
And Keras now is integrated
as part of TensorFlow.
And so TensorFlow has all
these layers of its library.
It has the low-level
stuff where it can
run on all sorts of platforms.
Then there's the
Python front end,
which still kind of TensorFlow
core and still relatively
low-level.
And then you have
the layers, which
is similar to the
Keras layers if you've
used that, which allows
you to construct your model
layer by layer.
And it's still
kind of low-level.
It's your hybrid step, call it.
And then above that, you
have this abstraction layer
where you can--
basically, it manages a
lot of the training cycle.
It takes care of--
gives you some pre-canned
models, things like that.
And that's kind
of where we'll be
operating at, but on the
Keras side of things.
So we'll build a custom
model and use Keras to do it.
But then we'll convert
that Keras model,
that trained Keras model,
to a TensorFlow Estimator.
And the current
only "good reason"
to do that in our
particular case is--
especially since we're
training it in Kaggle--
is that we need to export it
to a TensorFlow Estimator.
But why we need to
do that is because we
need to put it on
Cloud ML Engine, which,
for now at least, only accepts
TensorFlow SavedModel formats.
So it kind of forces
our hand there.
Now the typical reason you
would export a Keras model,
or at least convert a Keras
model, to an Estimator
is for the ability to do
better distributed training.
So typically you would--
if you were to
use them together,
you would construct
the Keras model.
But then, instead of
training it using Keras,
you would convert it
to TensorFlow Estimator
and train it as a
TensorFlow Estimator.
Because then you get
distribution and GPU
scaling for free in terms of
there's no additional work.
So that's the typical
kind of thinking there.
In this particular
case, we're going
to still continue training
it on the Keras path
and have a trained
Keras model that we then
take it through all the
rigors of exporting.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just the data--
YUFENG GUO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because if you're
using MNIST, or EMNIST,
or whatever, that comes
loaded with the Keras.
But if you have your
own data, and especially
if it's a big data set which
you can't just load into memory,
but you need to have that
whole Keras data directory
structure in your
[INAUDIBLE],, where do
you keep the data [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFENG GUO: Yeah,
so the question
is about what happens when
we have data that's bigger
than memory that's
not, quote, unquote,
"included with the
library," right?
So in this case, EMNIST,
I'm not using the one that's
included with the library.
So we'll actually see that.
We'll see-- we'll
use a generator,
we'll flow the data
from directories.
And so, yeah, we'll
get right to that.
Awesome.
Were there any other
questions before I continue?
Cool.
And then I think I had
one more slide here
just as a side note that there's
also canned Estimators that
are also--
they take care of even
more things for you.
And you don't have
to really manage
a lot of the underlying stuff.
So that's of less interest
in this particular use case.
OK, so Keras, as of 1.8, 1.7,
showed up inside TensorFlow
as tf.keras.
And you can pull it in.
If you have
TensorFlow installed,
Keras is already there.
And using the Keras that's
inside of TensorFlow
gives you access to
everything that Keras
has with the addition of
those Keras model to Estimator
conversion tools.
And some of the underlying
implementation is different,
but the interface-- or the
API abstraction layers--
are identical.
AUDIENCE: You said
that [INAUDIBLE]----
YUFENG GUO: Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Because the big
reason I wasn't using tf.keras--
I didn't know-- I don't
know-- is that the image data
generator, and also
this flow [INAUDIBLE],,
I didn't think that they
were there for the tf.keras,
but they were banned
in regular Keras.
YUFENG GUO: Right,
so the Keras that's
in TensorFlow is, line for
line, or at least the API, all
the calls you can make
for Keras are there.
It's strictly a superset.
So the stuff in
TensorFlow is just
Keras and a little
something extra, basically.
So you can-- the "ideal" is
you can take your Keras code,
your existing Keras code,
change that import to import
tensorflow--
from tensorflow import keras--
and be done.
So it's that degree of guarantee
in terms of identical API.
All right, so the
notebook is on Kaggle.
And if you don't want
to type the long URL,
you can type the shorter URL
that's still kind of long.
Man, this whole pattern--
long titles, long URLs.
So apologies for
that in advance.
And then I guess we'll--
my goal is to spend the
majority of the time
today actually going through the
code, and talking about that,
and answering your questions,
and being really engaged
in the discussion there.
All right-- oh yes,
question before we go on.
AUDIENCE: Question.
So like you mentioned, it's
a creative process, right?
So any time I want
to create some,
but I'm just with
the Keras [INAUDIBLE]
or whatever I'm doing, I
have to go through the Keras
to TensorFlow to save
model each time I do it?
YUFENG GUO: You're saying
if-- that's only if you want
to deploy that model, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
YUFENG GUO: And we'll see
by and large these steps
have been mostly automated.
So once you get the pipeline set
up, you're just running code.
So it's not like actual
work at that point,
but there's some setup.
OK, so if you want to that url
this should be what you see.
I have failed on my
[INAUDIBLE] links before,
so it wouldn't be the first
time it went to the wrong place.
If I can find my mouse.
OK.
So one of the neat things about
Keras for those of you who
aren't as familiar
with it is that it's--
go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Can you make the
text just a little bigger?
YUFENG GUO: Yes.
Thank you for reminding me.
We'll play with
these guys for now,
and if we need to
shrink it temporarily
later, if things that
wrong, flying off the page,
we can do that.
So one of the neat things about
Kaggle that I personally like
is that when you
put up a notebook--
they got around the problem
of Jupyter notebooks
being kind of
unreproducible, in that you
can run Jupyter notebook cells
in whatever order you want.
And then when you give
it to someone else,
if you weren't careful
about making sure
you ran everything
from top to bottom
in order with no repeats,
and did a little test
where you cleared everything and
started over, and you're like,
OK, it all works,
then you could really
hand someone a notebook
that doesn't really work
or they can't reproduce.
And so with the way Kaggle
forces your workflow,
you're editing the notebook and
then you hit commit and run,
and it commits the
notebook-- like, gets down
and saves your
versioning-- but then it
runs that notebook in a
separate virtual machine,
clean environment, top
to bottom, one cell
at a time in order.
And so it ensures that when
someone else takes your code
and tries to do
something with it,
it actually does the
thing it's expecting.
So at the top here it's just the
imports from TensorFlow import
Keras, as promised.
And some plotting, numpy,
pandas, the usual goodness.
The other piece
that is useful here,
as the woman friend mentioned
with the EMNIST dataset
is, I'm running this notebook
from the Keras dataset itself.
So assuming that
the wifi holds up,
and I haven't randomly
broken the Kaggle website,
this website will
eventually load.
We'll do-- oh now
I'll have it there.
Oh yeah, we'll do that.
So the dataset lives as a
bunch of different files,
and there's
information about it.
But basically it's
in this directory
relative to the position
of the notebook.
So I go and I set this
path, and I can read
in our training and test data.
The dataset itself is
actually organized by a bunch
of different kind of groupings.
There's this balanced
dataset, which
is meant to be the most
applicable in general.
And these are the stats around
how many examples there are,
and you have your 47 classes.
But there's also a
bunch of other ones
that are split differently,
and some of them
are significantly larger
or smaller, and you can--
this is from the paper from
when they released the dataset.
The one we're using
is this first one
which is balanced across
letters and numbers.
And so it's kind of nice to
work with, 3,000 of each.
And the other ones are
kind of all over the place,
but it's something that more
closely resembles, essentially,
the raw data that they had, and
they didn't normalize as much.
OK, so we'll go
through this early part
pretty straightforward.
You load the data, you
read it in, take a peek.
It's what you expect.
Kaggle has a tendency to
load everything in CSVs.
Obviously you do not have the
store all your data as CSVs,
but lots of zeros.
And the first column
is that label.
So here it really illustrates
the importance of, well,
what's 45 mean?
This took me a while
to figure out, right?
And we saw it in the slides,
but basically there's
this mapping where you've
got to get these letters
and numbers in the right
order so that when you look it
up later it actually works.
So like, if you get a
number up here that's 34,
I can just index
into that string,
and now I know it's a y.
So that's kind of how I
got around that problem.
And we can see
here our train data
is 112,000 rows, just as we
expected from balance dataset.
OK, so text got bigger.
Look at that.
Free size boost.
Now one of the things
about this data
is that, for whatever
reason, the way they stored
this data, right, it's flat.
So CSV, each row is
one letter or number.
We need to recombine
them into a 28
by 28 image, and the
standard way of--
when you do a standard
reshape, it actually
ends up with something that is
transposed and isn't a number.
So that's supposed to be a
k, just as FYI, in case it
wasn't clear.
Not pi, k.
And it's because
they're transposed,
so you want it to
look like that.
And so this is a good
opportunity for us
to illustrate a little
bit of preprocessing.
I'm just basically pulling
out the data, reshaping it,
and then calling numpy.transpose
and flipping the two axes--
the zeroth and first axes,
the first and zeroth.
And that gives us
our flipped result.
So we'll have do that every
time we want to show the image.
So I made a little function
to help us do that.
So now you don't have
to write that yourself.
The other piece of it
is understanding, like,
what we said earlier, that
the class number or the class
label, class 10, is
actually a capital A.
So when I'm naming these you
do the various lookups that you
need to do in order to obtain
both the index of the label
as well as the letter or
number it corresponds to.
So that all comes
together as one function.
We do our transpose,
and this is kind
of my preprocessing
function, basically.
Whenever I want to load the
dataset from the file name
to something that we can
use, this is what I'm doing.
Read in the file.
And then here I'm just
setting some values
in terms of the
dimension of the image.
I could just skip that and
just use hardcoded values.
And then we have our transpose.
Here the transpose is a little
more involved, because when
you actually grab the full
dataset and not just one image,
it's 112,000 rows
by 768 or 769--
one extra in the front.
So we have to just
flip the middle two,
because the first one
is the batch size.
So that's 112,800.
And the last one is
the dimensionality,
in this case one.
And so we switch them.
So instead of being 0,
1, 2, 3 it's 0, 2, 1, 3.
And then the final thing is
just kind of a bookkeeping step
to switch our labels to one
hot encoded just for the Keras
model to be able to
read that in properly.
So that changes it from being
1, 2, 3, 4 all the way to 46,
or zero through 46, to being
an array of 46 values, one
of which is a one and the others
are zeroes, the index of which
corresponds to the value.
Oh yes, and because these are
images, the number of times
I have forgotten to divide
by 255 for grayscale images,
and then subsequently
gotten terrible results,
and then went on Google
and stack overflow,
and it's like, you know,
predictions are crazy.
There's no result on the
internet that actually tells
you, like, if you
you're training
and your predictions
are wildly nuts,
and you can't figure
it out, you probably
forgot to divide by 255.
So there you have it.
Now it's on the internet.
Let's see, yes, now we've
got to make our model.
So looking back at our roadmap--
our road map is a far way back.
We got the data.
We did some adjustments,
some more adjustments,
and now we've got to create
our model architecture.
So in Keras, model creation
is relatively straightforward.
Some of you would agree,
some of you would disagree.
But we can set it up here.
I'm building a
convolutional network just
to take advantage of the fact
that we'll have a GPU in play,
so may as well have
it do something useful
rather than just training
a crappy network.
And given that we
have 47 classes,
it's possible that if I just did
a fully connected deep network
it might not actually
perform that well, right?
And then we have the
first convolutional layer.
I just chose some numbers.
I tried to keep it
small to make sure,
especially as I'm
iterating, it allowed
it to train a little faster.
I'm doing-- what am I doing?
12, 18, 24 depth filters,
five by five, three by three,
and two by two
kernels going through.
And just standard relu
activations with some drop
outs in the middle.
I'll pause here for questions
about model architecture.
Or is this pretty run of
the mill for folks here?
AUDIENCE: You're using
TensorFlow, right?
YUFENG GUO: OK, so the question
is, am I using TensorFlow.
I'm using Keras
inside TensorFlow.
So I'm using Keras in
terms of my syntax.
I'm using the Keras API
to construct the model.
And for all practical
considerations
I am using Keras.
After I create this
model you'll see here
I can call model.summary,
and it prints out exactly
as it would if you
were using Keras.
And after you train
a model like this,
if you were to do model.export
and you'd get a .save file.
It's the exact same
behavior to a t.
So yeah, then you do the.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFENG GUO: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you would
have a drop of about 0.5.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How did you come
up with 0.5 [INAUDIBLE]??
Is there logic behind it?
YUFENG GUO: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Is there
a logic behind it?
YUFENG GUO: Is there
a logic behind why
I chose 0.5 as the drop out?
I decided to go with
the aggressive drop
out to see what happened.
I think what happened
was, I originally
had much larger
convolutional layers
and so I was trying to
punish it a little more.
But then I shrunk it and
forgot to lower the drop out.
This isn't meant to
be a standard model.
I'm not mimicking any particular
paper or anything like that.
This is literally, I just
kind of back in the envelope
spitballed some numbers out.
The idea here is to demonstrate
the workflow of piecing
together the tooling,
not so much demonstrate
state of the art
convolutional network.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
YUFENG GUO: But
the good news is,
if you have a Keras model
that is really good,
you can literally just drop it
in the cell and everything else
should just work,
which is kind of nice.
At some point I was debugging,
and it was having trouble
getting the shapes and stuff,
so I made a little thing
to print out all the shapes.
You know, there's lists.
But these numbers
correspond exactly
to the numbers you
see in the summary,
so there's not a super
high yield use case here,
but there you have it.
You can get all the
shapes at every layer.
All right, let's train it up.
So training, as we
alluded to earlier,
we're going to use a generator.
And in particular I have a
couple of options here for you,
especially if you
take this notebook
and go and do stuff with it.
I just ran the vanilla
version, but I actually
wrote the code for the
other pieces as well.
There's the standard
image data generator
and there's also a
version with augmentation.
So if you pass in a
bunch of arguments--
I'm going to make this
smaller by a little bit
just so we can see the
arguments more easily
and it doesn't new
line itself to death.
The standard one I'm just
saying, just train it,
give a 20%, 80% validation
split of the training
data, whereas with this one you
can have it alter the image,
because they are images
and because we reshaped it
at the top.
Rather than passing them
in as arrays of 768,
we are actually passing
in 28 by 28 images.
So we can pass in all this
stuff around shifting the image
around, as well as
rotation, zoom, and shearing
of the image, the tweak.
And so that sort of stuff can
help introduce more variety
into your dataset if your
dataset isn't super large.
In this case, I have
112,000 examples.
I figured that's
probably OK for now.
And so I opted to just use
the normal data generator,
but thought this might be
handy, so I left it in here.
And so we pull out
our two generators.
So we call the generator.flow
and get our training
and validation generators,
and pass that in to do
model.fit_generator.
And for a while I
was doing 10 epochs.
10 epochs does work pretty
well here in terms of,
it gets much further along.
The sixth through
10th epoch do matter.
I just made it five for a
while, and probably forgot
to change it back because
it just runs faster, right?
And so when I was
testing I didn't
want to have it run forever.
So with five epochs
we got to 71%.
With five more, we're
closing in on 80.
And for this being
kind of a back
of the envelope, random
network, it's not the worst.
It's of course, as you
mentioned, certainly not
the best network in the world.
And it's certainly not trained
to any crazy degree either.
So at this point we have
a trained model, right?
And then we can call evaluate
and pass in our test data
generator that we made here.
The valuation, I'm always
impressed at how concise
that can be.
It's very similar to the
training code in that we
load in the data the same way,
just passing the test data
path instead of the
train data path,
and then the data generator is
very straightforward to call
and there's not much in the
way of arguments since when you
do evaluation you
only need to pass
through the dataset one time
instead of looping it over
and over and over.
The numbers that are
coming out here--
the first number is the
loss, and the second number
is the accuracy.
So on our test dataset,
we're getting about 77%,
which is kind of
like, not the worst.
For being kind of random, I
threw some numbers together
and was like, I'll take it.
Let's see.
Yeah, and then just a brief
look at some predictions.
Here's one such example.
This is the letter d,
in case it wasn't clear.
It's like an upside-down p.
And when we load it in--
sorry, this one.
I think I might have
just been visualizing.
And then I decided
to, instead of trying
to pick numbers myself, I
just picked 10 random ones.
These are the 10
that happened to run.
So the predictions
are on the first row,
and the labels are
in the second--
the correct label.
So you can see we
got some wrong.
We got most of them right.
We got that one wrong,
we got that one-- that's
the same one that got wrong.
Look at that.
So whatever 41 is,
this g, it keeps
thinking that whatever
44 is actually a g.
So if 41 is g--
a, b, c, d, f, g, h, i, j.
So j's and g's, you could see
how that might look similar.
And for a lowly
trained CNN model
it might struggle
in that department.
Here's an n, for those
who were wondering
what the n's look like.
It kind of looks like an
upside-down n for some reason.
Some more letters.
Anyways, so that's prediction.
So far everything we've see
is kind of your standard Keras
stuff, right?
There's nothing
that we've really
looked at that's super
wacky, or you know, aside
from TensorFlow Import
Keras, everything else so far
could have just been how to
train a convolutional network
using Keras.
So let's see, if we move on
from the kind of creating
model training and
such, we get to some
of the interesting pieces here.
So Keras.estimator, this
is one of the pieces
that were added to
Keras in the version
that inside of TensorFlow.
So normal Keras does not
have a dot estimator module.
And so you have this
estimator.model to estimator.
Basically it's a
conversion function.
It's a utility function that
will take your Keras model.
And right now I have the
model as a Python pointer.
I just have that in a variable.
You could also-- if you
had a Keras model that
had been previously exported
there's a different argument.
I think it's like Keras
directory, or something.
For the file name, you can pass
in the exported file directly.
You wouldn't have to load
it first and then put it in.
It'll take care of that for you.
And so you could also get a
model that someone else is
giving you, or saying
like, hey, I've
got this thing if you
want to try it out.
And you're like,
oh, I want to do xyz
but use TensorFlow estimators.
Go for it.
And so then once
you have the model,
the estimator does
need a place to live.
So this model directory
is the directory
for the estimator model, not the
directory for the Keras model.
So that's why I tried
to give it a good name,
like estimator model, so
I wouldn't get confused.
And the only other side note
I would give here is that,
when you use this-- if you
were to use this to convert
to an estimator and then
actually do more training
on it-- which we could, but
we're not going to in this
case--
the input functions
that you use need
to have kind of a name
for what to call the--
I forget the proper term.
But basically there's the key
to the dictionary of inputs.
And that key is com2d
input in this case.
So you grab it from
the model.input names
that's coming from
the Keras model,
because you couldn't
explicitly set it.
Because it was built from
Keras, Keras sets it for you.
So next we're going to take
the TensorFlow estimator model,
and now we need to
export it as a file.
So to do that it's
a little bit more
involved, because what
we're going to do is we're
going to set it up that we
can read in JPEGs and PNG
images directly, rather than
reading in a row of a CSV file,
because that's not an image.
We built a CNN.
These are supposed to
be handwritten letters
and numbers.
So if you were to imagine
writing a production
service which had
to do this task,
wouldn't you be
sending images encoded
over the wire and not
an array of numbers
encoded as an array
with commas between?
Like, it would just be
terribly sized inefficient.
So you would encode
it using Base64
on a JPEG, or Base64 on a PNG,
and send that over the wire.
And so to take that and
then remunge it back
to a long array of
numbers, manually no less,
just doesn't feel right.
And so what I would
recommend here doing is,
TensorFlow has a
number of utilities
to help us create this
serving input function.
So the inputs to the model when
it's serving predictions can be
different-- can have kind
of a different head--
than what is used when
we're doing training.
So in our case, we did training
in Keras anyway, so that's done
and we're set.
And what I'm doing here--
I'll try to walk through
this as clearly as possible,
because it is easy to get lost--
is we used some raw TensorFlow
pieces here to get this done.
So the first piece is the
TensorFlow placeholder.
A placeholder is basically
what it sounds like.
It holds the place for
where data will come in.
So this is where
the binary image--
the Base64 encoded byte string--
will land.
So it's a string, and
it is zero dimensions.
And so we're calling
this input_ph. ph
is short for placeholder here.
And what we're going to do with
that is we're going to call
TF.decode_images.
And what that does is,
it will take an image
and decode it into, in this
case, unsigned int8 array of--
a numpy array.
A tensor of unsigned int8.
And so there's a couple
of things happening here,
but at the core of it
this is what is notable.
We're saying, from
here decode this.
And what we're calling to
make that happen is map.
So we're going to
use map to map decode
onto whatever is falling
into the input placeholder.
Decode image, however takes
as a default argument channels
is three.
It's expecting a color image.
But our images are grayscale.
There's only one channel.
And so because this argument
here, the first argument
of map, is a function,
not a function call,
I'm using the Python functools
to do a wrap around it.
And it's essentially
a lambda where I just
set the channels to one.
So now when it
calls this, channels
will be set to one by default.
And so it's a little bit
convoluted.
I probably could
have broken that out
into a separate
line, what I just
highlighted, and just called
that, like, custom decode
image.
And so we say map
function our decode image
onto input placeholder, and the
output type is unsigned int8.
And then we're going to cast
that, because the defaults are
this, and we do want it to use
a TensorFlow cast to float 32,
and then of course--
I almost forgot to do this--
divide by 255.
All right.
So that's kind of our images.
So we have
transformed our input,
which was just a placeholder
because we don't know what's
coming in yet, into a grayscale
image that was divided by 255.
The final thing we
need to do is to know
that decode image actually is
smart and knows the dimensions
of an image coming in.
And so the image
that it spits out,
or the 2D array that it spits
out, will be those dimensions.
And because of that, we do
not know at compile time,
so to speak, what the
dimensions of an image will be,
because that happens at runtime.
This runs into a
problem later on where,
when the model tries to export,
it says, I don't know what
dimensions you're going to use.
And so that's why we
need this final line
where we set the shape.
This isn't explicitly changing
the image, it's more of,
you think of it as
like an annotation.
Is It's kind of a, let me give
you some more information--
some more details.
It's like metadata--
and tag it as none,
which is the batch size.
You can pass in
three images, you
can pass in 70 images,
one image, whatever.
And then it's going
to be 28 by 28
by one, because we
have one channel.
It's grayscale.
And then we're going to do,
we have input placeholder
and we have images.
Those are our two things.
And we're going to use that--
here we have images and input
placeholder.
We're going to use
these two as arguments
to the serving input receiver.
And this is a wrapper
utility function
that would generate
what we need to tack on
to the top of our model to
use as an input function
for serving predictions.
And so I'm choosing
to use the model input
name, that com2d_input.
And the second argument I
would recommend using bytes.
And we'll see why, but just
believe me for now that we'll
use bytes as the argument.
But you could
theoretically change it.
But if you do change it,
it should end in _bytes.
So bytes is fine.
And then when we pass in here
is images and the placeholder.
So basically it's saying,
the first argument
is what will be
going into the model,
and the second argument
is what is coming
in at the top before that--
the placeholder.
And then all this code maps
the two together above it.
So that's the serving
input function.
This is probably
the most in-depth
that I've ever tried to explain.
There's so many things going on,
and it's hard to get it right.
So hopefully if you have
a use case similar to this
you can take this code and
just largely used it as is.
So the step you get after that
is a lot more straightforward
because we did all the work.
You call export save
model on our estimator,
and we pass in-- wow making
it bigger made it bigger.
We pass in a directory.
I just make a
folder called export
to stick it in, and
pass in that function
that we spend all that time
kind of working through.
And I just print out the export
path to take a glance at it.
So this is an
auto-generated timestamp.
And that's why I like to
put in a subdirectory,
otherwise you're
just going to get
a bunch of these at the top
level and it's just a mess.
I also included the Keras
exports, just for fun.
And so we save the
Keras model using
the separated ways, the JSON and
h5 weights and model structure,
as well as the full model
weights and structure together.
So now when I do ls,
us what we see here
is we have our export folder
that had all that stuff.
We have our full
model from Keras.
We have our model.h5
and model.json,
and we have an
estimator model, which
is also a folder which contains
checkpoints that you could--
if you wanted to-- take and
train further in TensorFlow.
So that's kind of the training,
evaluation, conversion, export
workflow.
AUDIENCE: Just one question.
The estimator model is
just weights, right?
YUFENG GUO: The estimator
model folder is--
yeah.
The checkpoints only
contain weights.
You're right.
And I just have a simple
plot for accuracy,
which is pretty useless here,
because we did only 40 epochs.
But you can see how,
if I kept training,
it would actually improve.
Like, we're not really
done training yet,
but it's more of a
placeholder for if you
take this and do more
interesting stuff with it
than I have.
You have a little
chart that you can use.
Loss is the same way.
And we're going to
pause here, and we'll
come back to this notebook
and do the rest of it
once we have a use
for it shortly.
So let me show you the output.
So as promised, there's
a bunch of outputs.
Some of these outputs
we haven't seen yet
because I create them later.
But basically in the export
folder there is saved_model.pb
and our two variables.
Those are the weights.
So this will come out as--
let's see here.
Don't mind the random--
there we go.
All right, downloads.
No way to make this
bigger, though.
Or is there?
Nope, no way to
make this bigger.
So this is, when you
click on the model
and you hit Download All, you
get a zip, and you unzip it,
and you get this.
And then you have things
like your saved_model.bp
and variables.
And so you can just
take this entire folder
and upload it to a
bucket on Google Cloud.
So in my case, I've created
a folder in here called
emnist_Keras2tf--
Keras to TensorFlow-- and then
inside that folder I've been--
wow, this is a terrible
zoom experience.
And inside that folder I've
created a couple versions,
because this has gone
through several cycles.
The V3 ones seem to work.
You have our .pb
and our variables.
And so when we want to create
a new model with Cloud ML
Engine, what that looks
like is, you go to ML Engine
and you go to Models.
And you can click Create Model.
And when you say Create Model,
really it's just a wrapper.
It's literally a name and a
description and nothing else.
So say I call it
something like this.
And you know, hey,
I created a model.
So it's here.
And there's nothing in here,
and there's no versions.
So we need to create a version
to actually do something
with it.
So when we create a version,
we click Create Version.
And we can give it a name.
This name is permanent
within that version.
Now of course you can
delete the version
and make a new one
and stuff, but it
does need to be unique
within a given model.
So let's call this maybe
first version, or v1, or v.1.
And there's a runtime
selection here.
Cloud ML Engine maps to a
couple of different runtimes.
These quote-unquote
"runtimes" have behind them
different versions of
TensorFlow, different versions
of various other
Python libraries
that you might care to
use in your Python code.
I typically just select the most
recent one because, you know,
I've been using the most
recent version of TensorFlow.
But there are those who are
using, for example, TensorFlow
1.0 still.
They're using it in production,
and so this supports kind
of compatibility back to then.
There's a whole list of the
different versions of what
libraries are in each one.
I would recommend
selecting it manually,
because it will default you to
1.0, and then you will be sad.
So if we copy this out, and
we take this directory--
so what it wants is
a directory-- whoops,
I didn't want a
definition of it--
a directory of where
these files live.
So you notice here that because
TensorFlow exports the models
not as a single file but as
a folder of various things,
you want to always
make sure there's
a wrapping folder for it,
otherwise it can get messy,
right?
So it needs to be a folder with
nothing but these two files.
And you'll also notice
that, as I highlight this,
this is basically what
you need to paste in.
This is the bucket
name, and then these
are folders in the path to it.
You can hit Browse and
navigate your way there,
but if you already
have this open,
you've just finished
uploading the files and stuff,
you may well just copy it over.
However, when I do that
I am greatly saddened,
because it says
Folder Not Available.
And the reason for that--
and I say reason, but I say
that in a very weak sense
of the word reason--
is that it is
looking for a folder.
And the UI argues that
a folder must always
end in a trailing slash.
So I will now press slash.
Ta-da.
So this is my note to the UI
team that is building this.
And so if they had
a slash here, we
could just copy paste
that over, right?
And then we wouldn't
need to worry about it.
So that's my latest gripe.
So remember the trailing
slash and you will not
be disappointed.
Or you can use the Browse
thing and just select,
and it will populate it for you.
But it'll create its version.
It'll do its thing.
All of the operations that
we're doing on the UI right
now are accessible via
API and command line,
so you can use command line to
do this, script out on dash.
Or you can call it through
the Python API, the Ruby API,
the Go API, Java API--
whatever you want-- and
automate it using that.
So there's a lot
of options there
that you can use the APIs
to create versions, create
models, delete them, edit
them, change the name--
well, you can't change the name.
The name is
permanent, but you can
delete it and create a new one.
And you can do all those things.
So you can automate
the whole process.
You can add testing in, and
various kind of pipeline,
almost like CI/CD
but for machine
learning, to that effect.
So it's going to
create its thing,
and it's going to take a
while, because sometimes it
takes a while.
But luckily we
created one earlier.
And I created one--
let's see, let's
go to our models.
And I called it
emnist_kaggle_Keras.
And I failed the first time,
but the third time's the charm.
And so I called it v1, v2, v3.
The name of the call
emnist_kaggle_Keras.
And my window is behaving.
OK.
Find the thing.
Promise I will make this bigger.
Oh this is going to be really
good when I unplug later.
Everything's going to be huge.
So to make this call,
we need to, basically--
I did a bunch of
experiments recently.
OK, so we call it gcloud
ml-engine predict.
And we say, what model was it--
just that same string name.
We say what version it was--
in our case v3.
And then we have to pass
in this input data file.
And so this brings us back
to where we were earlier.
I promised we'd go back to
the notebook, and we are.
So let's go down
past all the stuff
we saw earlier and look at--
after the graphs-- as soon as
my computer decides to scroll--
we're going to create some
prediction files for ourselves.
I had this originally
in a separate Python
script on my local machine,
then I realized, wait,
we can just do this
in then notebook
and then you all have access
to the code, which is great.
I used the same call to-- that
whole transpose business that
we did at the beginning--
to take whatever row of
data and do the thing where
you transposed the values.
Then we can use the PIL
library to pull out an image--
render the image from an array.
So originally this
array is actually n64,
and so it will complain
at you, so you need
to cast it it as unsigned n8.
But then you have your image.
And then I use the
same code that we
saw before that I used to
label those images with both
the class name-- the
label 47, 32, whatever--
and figure out the letter that
it corresponds to, to make
a nice file name for myself.
So it will be class
something, label j,
or something like that.
And we're going to
export one of them.
And so that will
give us a PNG, right?
And so now with that PNG file
we need to Base64 encode it.
So the steps, they keep coming.
And so we have our
class 19 label j PNG,
and we're going to encode that
into JSON and call that file
class_19_label_j.json.
And so to do that
we'll read in our PNG
file, and Base64 encode it.
Note that Base64
encodes in Python 3
behaves differently
than Python 2.
And those of you who
have experienced it
are smiling and
nodding right now.
Rest assured that the first
time I encountered this,
I was not smiling nor nodding.
It is horrendous, because
it comes out as bytes.
And you know what's not bytes?
Strings.
Which is what you want.
And you know what else you
can't encode into JSON?
Bytes.
And so you try to call
this and it doesn't work,
and then you realize
all you have to do
is wrap STR around it
and it works, or change
your environment to Python 2.
So those are your choices.
And then so once you have
that, and you printed a bunch,
and you're sure that
you're doing it right,
and you're like, ah-ha,
you can write it to a file.
And that's the most
straightforward thing ever.
You just dump it
out into a file.
And this is our Base64
encoded letter j.
I know it doesn't
look super compact,
but it's much better than 764
grayscale numbers with commas
in between them, and spaces.
And so that's kind of the final
bit of the story and Kaggle,
is that we're going to use
the output abilities of this
to kind of output us our
class_19_label_j.json,
which we can then use when
we want to call our model.
Incidentally, I wonder if our
model finished, because then we
can actually call it and prove
to you all that it worked.
So it finished.
Loading it up.
So let's see.
It decided to refresh itself.
So we want to say, Google
AI Huddle is the name
of our-- where is--
I have so many windows.
OK, so we want to say model
name equals Google AI Huddle.
Version name.
Does anyone remember
the version?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFENG GUO: I have
many mixed things.
So yeah, the old one was
v3, but we're changing
to this new model, right?
I don't actually
remember it, and no one
is speaking loudly enough.
First version.
Yes.
First_version.
And the data file I
already actually have set,
but I'll show you.
It's class_19_label JSON.
And I do have both the JSON
and the other file here.
But there's the JSON.
We can look at it, I guess.
That's probably more
useful than just seeing it.
As can be expected,
now what I've done here
is I've wrapped it
in two pieces here.
One is bytes.
Remember we said bytes earlier?
I want to use bytes in
our serving function.
So this is the word bytes
that maps to that word.
So it's kind of a random word.
You can put whatever you want.
So it doesn't really matter.
But almost all of the
samples will use bytes.
And b64, so you need
another layer inside,
which is another thing and
sometimes will trip people up.
At any rate, we've
set our values.
So let's-- oh, I never
actually ran this line.
So let's just run it.
So this is the
command line utility
that you can use to
interact with Google Cloud.
And it will come back
with a mess of numbers.
So this is the other funny
thing about this, right?
It's like, what is all this?
These are the probabilities
of each of the 47 classes.
And so what we really want--
right, it's like, tell
me what I really want--
is to run argmax.
And so we get 19.
And if you'll recall,
our file was 19, j.
We can also open--
what was it?
Close it, yeah.
And I think it's PNG.
Oh good, we can't
open it apparently.
But we can pull it
up in other ways.
Downloads, oh I
had it somewhere.
It's a tiny j.
Right?
[WEAK APPLAUSE]
And then we have 19.
Yeah.
So that's kind of
the crazy journey.
AUDIENCE: J for journey.
YUFENG GUO: J for journey.
Yes, thank you-- that it
takes to get from you taking
the data--
so we did all of that stuff
to get it set up, right?
And we train our model, which
you can train however you want.
And then on the flip
side, we did all of that.
And that was like the first bit.
And then we spent the rest of
the time hooking everything
else up together.
But once we have
this hooked together,
notice that all the pieces
are entirely scriptable,
and almost all the code
was in Kaggle kernel.
And so you can imagine--
I haven't actually
deployed this--
but you can imagine
a situation where
you can have kind of a
real-time-ish situation
where you have code
commits going in one side
to your training models.
You have something
coming out, and then you
can drop it in a folder
that gets picked up.
And then all these steps happen.
And then at the end of it,
you have a deployed model
that's ready to serve.
One of the things that
I like about the cloud,
and I'll mention this kind
of prediction side of things,
is that, as easy
as it is to create
that version, while it does
feel like we didn't really
earn having a globally
productionized model
that scales automatically
based on demand, is secure,
has a REST API for free along
with all the client libraries
across all of the
six major languages
that Google Cloud supports,
you feel like we didn't really
earn that, right?
We just gave it a name,
pointed it to a directory,
and just said, like, all
right, do all the things.
And those things are like
replicating across servers
across the world.
It's available now, right?
It's available to be called at
scale, and from any device that
connects to the internet.
So it means you can call it
from your phones, an app,
you can call it
from IOT devices.
It means that you
can get predictions
from edge devices that are
connected to a network.
You can do that.
And obviously from web
and servers and things.
So wow, we are really far
back in the presentation.
OK, go back.
So yeah, we talked
about the tooling.
We've kind of fit
this together, right?
There were definitely some
rough edges here and there.
It's not a one click, oh
we're done, look at that,
because that would make for
a much less interesting talk.
But piecing these pieces
together is both--
it can be frustrating.
But the end result--
we're getting to a point where
the end result is oftentimes
more valuable and worth it--
worth the pain, so to speak.
And everything gets smoother
and smoother over time,
so this tooling will
get better and better.
But in the meantime you can
reap the benefits, especially
because even though it's hard
to put together initially,
it can be set up as the
reproducibly deployed pipeline
that you can use to keep
pushing out predictions,
keep pushing out new models,
new versions, doing A/B testing,
things like that.
And as more tools
come online, as you
are familiar with
all these pieces,
you can imagine
branching off, right?
It's like you train along, you
do this thing, you deploy here.
Maybe you're chaining
a TensorFlow model
and now we're going
to convert to Keras.
You can do the reverse.
You can instead of
doing it on Kaggle,
maybe you're running
a notebook locally,
and then you can export and
do the same sort of thing.
So a lot of this
knowledge carries
across multiple
disciplines, in a way.
Yes, questions?
AUDIENCE: The model you just
mentioned about, from the Keras
to TensorFlow, is that OK
for the model generated
by the Pytorch or different
kind of the framework?
YUFENG GUO: So the technique
that we're looking at here
is a kind of utility
that's inside of Keras--
the one that's
inside of TensorFlow.
So it's specifically
a piece added to Keras
to enable the conversion
of Keras models
to TensorFlow estimators.
As far as existing
tools, I'm not actually
familiar enough
with the existing
tools around conversion of
Pytorch models to TensorFlow
models.
I think I saw something
to that effect.
I'm not sure about, like,
officially supported tools,
though.
Like, this is an officially
supported converter
from Keras models to
TensorFlow models.
And that's also part
of the appeal of it.
Like, everything I was showing
you here today, none of it
is some experimental side
project that may or may not
exist next week.
It's all things
that are essentially
deployable in production.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick question.
I'm not familiar with the
media if there are tools
that were found in [INAUDIBLE].
So let's say you
want to be deployed
[INAUDIBLE] fine tuning.
Do [INAUDIBLE]
allow us to do that?
Or maybe even [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFENG GUO: So the
question is around,
if I deployed a v1
of a model and now I
want to fine-tune
that model, what
tools are available in
Google Cloud to achieve that.
So when you deploy
a model, that's
kind of you're
serving model, right?
You saw the code where
we called export,
and we supplied a
serving function.
When you call
export saved model,
some of the things it's doing
conceptually, you can imagine,
is that the weights in the
model are being frozen.
And so whereas when
you're training
you want to, obviously, allow
the weights to be updated,
and when you deploy
the model, you just
want this model to run
as fast as possible
to spit out predictions, right?
So when you want
to do fine tuning,
you should go back to the
model you were training,
pick up where you left off,
and do your fine tuning there.
And so you can
almost think of it--
it's similar to kind
of developing code
when you have your
main trunk of code,
and then you have releases.
And if you want to tune
your code, so to speak,
you wouldn't take that release
back and unpackage it and start
working from that source.
You wouldn't decompile
your code or anything.
You already have
your source code.
You would just
continue working along,
and later on, you know, next
week you have another release.
So similarly to here,
you're training your model.
You export it,
and you deploy it.
You can keep training it.
You can keep tweaking it.
And you can deploy another one.
And when you do, you could do
kind of split AB testing, where
you put some traffic to one
and some traffic to the other.
Because when you actually call
these endpoints as we saw,
you specify not just the model
name, but also the version.
So you could put some
kind of load balancing
or AB split testing if
you wanted on top of that,
and say, call version
this, then a little bit
on that, just to make sure that
I didn't just break everything
by deploying a new model.
AUDIENCE: So what targets do
you support for the estimator?
So obviously you support
the Google Cloud target.
But Google also has edge
devices with machine learning
accelerators built in.
Do you support those
as targets as well?
YUFENG GUO: So the
question is around
whether we support
exporting saved models
to be deployed on devices aside
from Cloud Machine Learning
Engine.
In particular, edge devices.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
YUFENG GUO: So the format
of the saved model--
of export saved model it's
the TensorFlow model export
format of choice.
And from that you can kind of
go in a number of directions.
It's the most
versatile, so to speak,
of the choices in
terms of formats.
And you can kind of
down-convert, so to speak,
to other things.
So the version we're using
for a Cloud ML Engine,
it's just directly.
No further conversion needed.
But you can use things like XLA,
or Accelerated Linear Algebra
libraries, which is
part of TensorFlow,
and take that and use that
to alter your exported model
in ways that make it
more suitable for running
on edge devices, that cause
it to shrink the model
and things like that.
AUDIENCE: OK, but do the
devices make it proprietary?
So for instance, Intel
has a [INAUDIBLE]
that Google has integrated into
one of their products slots.
They have a compiler.
They use this facility
called freeze graph.
But I'm personally having
issues with version skew.
Every time I run
into a new issue,
then I have to rebuild
my entire tools slot.
YUFENG GUO: Wow, OK.
AUDIENCE: And so I'm trying to
get away from that activity.
But is there a way
that I could come up
with a compiler
that would take--
let's say, I wanted
to target this device,
because it's proprietary.
So is there any
effort or intention
to support these devices?
YUFENG GUO: So the
devices are devices
that are coming from,
in this example,
this partnership between
Intel and Google?
AUDIENCE: Well,
it's a partnership
between Google and Intel.
They have some neuromorphic
chip sites, and various--
so they're faster than GPUs and
they're targeted specifically
for machine learning algorithms.
And they seem to
be one-offs now.
So for instance,
you have a camera
and it does facial recognition
and so forth on the image.
But it doesn't export it to the
cloud to do the recognition.
It does it on the thing.
YUFENG GUO: So you're
saying you want
to load your own models onto
those pieces of hardware?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
YUFENG GUO: Interesting.
All right, and are those
devices open for developers?
Like, there's an STK to?
AUDIENCE: So there is a,
in this particular case,
I can take [INAUDIBLE] and I
can develop a model from, say,
[INAUDIBLE], what have your.
YUFENG GUO: Sure.
AUDIENCE: But it's 32 bit
floating point, obviously.
YUFENG GUO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And then there's
a [INAUDIBLE] supply
that compiles down
to the target.
YUFENG GUO: OK, yeah,
that's typically the XLA.
AUDIENCE: But this is
outside of this export.
Because what I see-- what I
believe we're headed towards
is, we have the front end
where we do the development
and create the internal
architecture of our software
versus hardware.
But then we may want
to export to the cloud,
we may want to export
it to multiple devices
to support acceleration through
device-specific translators.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And if there
is a single reference
point for doing
that export, then it
makes the whole process easier.
YUFENG GUO: Agreed.
AUDIENCE: I guess that
would be my comment.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
it's a great comment.
So we'll continue that.
Just a real quick announcement.
We're going to do
a paper survey.
YUFENG GUO: Oh, a paper survey.
AUDIENCE: So we'll do that
right now while you're here.
And please [INAUDIBLE]
continue asking your questions.
YUFENG GUO: Cool.
So to kind of talk about the.
AUDIENCE: So for those
who are filling out,
we will have a
raffle at the end.
[INAUDIBLE] will be calling
a number on the top right,
so make sure you
record down your number
so you end up with one
fancy fax [INAUDIBLE]
YUFENG GUO: Cool.
Yeah, so make sure
you remember-- yeah.
There's a raffle at the end.
So remember your numbers.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't have a
raffle though, but we can.
YUFENG GUO: It's a
separate thing, yeah.
So yeah, your
comment coming around
kind of architecture-specific
deployments.
I think where we're
at today, we basically
have a situation
where, when you export
a model to this expert saved
model, that's like the full--
it captures the full
richness of your model--
its weights, its structure,
everything, right?
That's the highest
fidelity version.
And then typically
what happens is
you then start tearing it
down for other architectures.
You start adjusting, you
start fiddling with it.
And so I would imagine that
at least for the majority
of architectures,
we're kind of getting
to a point where, especially
with the XLA compiler,
is extensible to make it
suitable for other kinds
of architectures.
So obviously you don't want
to be in the compiler writing
business.
But the idea is that
others, the makers
of those chips, the
makers of those chipsets,
can then use that
specification and kind of of
extend XLA to enable these
kinds of conversions.
Yeah, so kind of like
a hub and spoke model.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
YUFENG GUO: Other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what [INAUDIBLE]
very easily scale up
to five million [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFENG GUO: Five million what?
AUDIENCE: New predictions.
YUFENG GUO: New predictions
per day, per second?
Like five million per
what unit of time?
Like, are you saying just
the raw amount or the rate?
AUDIENCE: The rate.
YUFENG GUO: The rate.
So five million
in how much time?
AUDIENCE: A second?
YUFENG GUO: A second.
Yeah, so what's the current
scale of making predictions
with ML Engine?
A lot of it is going to
depend on your model,
like the size of the model,
the size of those images
you're sending, and
if they're images.
The other piece of it
is, it will probably
take a second to ramp up,
especially if you're dumping it
with a lot.
So those first couple might
be a little slower, but then
as it scales out horizontally
and spins up more servers
to respond to the
increased request load,
it will certainly become
more and more performing.
Robbie, do you have any
comments on what kind
of benchmark testing
you've done in terms
of just back of the
envelope performance?
ROBBIE: So the most
important thing
is how long each
prediction takes.
Like, if it takes a
millisecond, obviously we
can do a lot more QPS, because
that requires fewer resources.
And if it takes 10 seconds
then we can do a lot fewer.
But the general rule
of thumb, I would say,
is I think you can do about
1,000 QPS with a really
simple quota request.
If you want to do
about 10,000 or above,
we most likely can do it,
but you'll need to contact us
and we'll need to work to make
sure we have enough resources.
But we can easily go
above that and beyond.
So just contact us
if you're interested.
YUFENG GUO: Awesome.
Another question?
Or a follow-up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
much more expensive
ETL in a different
domain, would you
do it on Spark in the cluster,
and then upload the output
and then do it that way?
YUFENG GUO: If you had
much more expensive ETL
for training or for prediction?
AUDIENCE: For
prediction as well.
YUFENG GUO: Oh.
So yeah, I guess that
would depend on the domain,
especially if you're willing
to go out to a separate system
to do ETL, it sounds like you're
doing batch prediction then,
not kind of online
responsive prediction.
But then you can do a fair
amount of ETL on TensorFlow.
But yeah, if you want to do
kind of mass transformations,
you should use whatever tools
you are comfortable with.
If you want to stay
within Google Cloud,
you can run that
Spark on Dataproc.
And if you're kind of
developing a new set of ETL,
you can also use things
like a Beam on Dataflow.
So Beam is an Apache open source
kind of ETL transformation tool
that allows you to use the
same source code to transform
both stream and batch data.
That's where the
name comes from--
Beam is batch and stream.
And you can run it
on Dataflow, which
is intended to be kind of a
next generation ETL service
where you can just, basically--
it's sort of like the way
a [INAUDIBLE] works where
you can just submit your code
and it will just run.
You don't have to
think about machines,
and the size of the machines,
and how many machines.
It's just, here's my Beam
code, here's my data,
go make it happen.
And it paralyzes
everything for you.
So that part of it's nice.
The final piece of it
would be tf.Transform,
which is a library
for doing-- you
guessed it-- transformations.
It's based on the
Beam API so there's
a lot of similarities
there which allow you
to kind of carry things over.
But by and large,
those would be some
of the options in that space.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So if you have
an orchestration language?
YUFENG GUO: Oh right.
ROBBIE: So once you've deployed
your model like you saw there,
you have access to the
batch prediction API
which will allow you to do--
it's throughput optimized.
And so we don't
really talk about QPS.
It's more about-- it autoscales
to as many workers as you want,
and so you could use
that in an ETL pipeline
if you're using some
orchestration system Like Argo
or Cloud Composer, which is
airflow for that type of thing.
There's another option.
YUFENG GUO: So a lot
options out there
for kind of moving data around.
AUDIENCE: I can start
calling off numbers.
YUFENG GUO: The exciting part.
This is why you all came, right?
You saw the long title, and
then you were like, wait,
but I can get a backpack.
Other questions while we
wait for numbers to appear?
Oh, I also recently
learned that if you
type into Google search,
random number between x and y--
like, a random number
being 50 and 73,
it will just return
a number for you.
Don't ask me why
I thought of that.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So once you have
[INAUDIBLE] model, a trained
[INAUDIBLE] model, you can also
use this module to [INAUDIBLE]
and then you can train
the model [INAUDIBLE]..
Let's say you are doing
that on a local machine.
Is there an advantage
to [INAUDIBLE]??
YUFENG GUO: None that I know of.
So the question is around, so
once you have a model defined
in Keras, you have two choices.
You can continue and
train it in Keras,
or you can convert
it to TensorFlow
and train it in TensorFlow.
Right, so you have these
parallel paths that diverge,
and then they can kind
of come back together.
And on a local machine is
there any advantage to training
on Keras versus training
on a TensorFlow estimator?
Off the top of my head I can't
think of any in particular,
but maybe [INAUDIBLE] has
some more extended thoughts.
PUNEITH KAUL: Yeah,
so basically Keras
is the official TensorFlow
model authoring layer.
So you want to use Keras to
author your architecture.
The dispatch and the
execution of the model
itself should be done
through estimate API.
What that means is that
your authoring language now
is much less verbose, and
it has all the same benefits
of TensorFlow, because
the underlying execution
engine is actually TensorFlow.
So that was actually an
official thing from TensorFlow,
and that's why you
want to use a df Keras,
because it subsumes
the open source Keras.
YUFENG GUO: And the
rationale behind
why we recommend converting
to estimator in general,
and training on the
estimator-- it's
like, I already
have a Keras model,
why don't I just
train it as it is?
Is, if my understanding
is correct,
more based around the
fact that should you
want to then move
to a larger dataset,
maybe several GPUs hooked
up to the same machine,
moving to any number
of cloud environments,
those sorts of things
then become a lot easier
and become basically
seamless if you already
have a TensorFlow estimator.
And there's also certain
benefits in terms of the code.
The conversion can be
made a little bit easier
in certain spots if you
convert it and train it as-is
rather than trying to
convert it afterwards.
PUNEITH KAUL: There's
actually one more benefit.
So how many of you have
heard of [INAUDIBLE]??
It actually uses this
strategy called allreduce.
So TensorFlow now has in
contrib a distribution strategy.
So you basically
can tell TensorFlow
whether you want to use a PSS,
or workers, or allreduce, ring
allreduce, which is a
much better technique
to do distribution.
And that you can plug in with
the estimator very seamlessly.
So that's another
benefit of doing that.
YUFENG GUO: It seems like the
push is really around keeping
the Keras APIs kind of
clean and readable as
possible while leveraging
the benefits of the estimator
distribution strategies and
distribution technology that's
under the hood there.
Cool.
Any other questions
before we move
to random number generator?
Please.
AUDIENCE: Would that be
easier to develop a prototype
and carry over just actually
doing it on the TensorFlow?
YUFENG GUO: Is this question
whether or not it's easier
to develop a prototype?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
strategy proposition
that it's [INAUDIBLE]
platform [INAUDIBLE]
innovation principle.
It's supposed to be easier of
rapid prototyping and all that.
Is that true with
[INAUDIBLE] versus I
go directly to TensorFlow
to to prototyping?
YUFENG GUO: For prototyping,
I mean a lot of it's
going to depend on your use
case and the kind of data
that you have.
I can see the
benefits both ways.
Like, on one side Keras has
an arguably simpler API,
and perhaps fewer concepts
that you have to learn.
So I guess part of it
is the question of,
do you already know one of these
two libraries going into it.
And so there's a
different comparison.
If you say, I know Keras
and I know TensorFlow.
Which one should I use?
Versus, I don't know either,
which one should I learn?
Which one is better?
Which is faster?
In those two use
cases, it can kind of
lead to different
considerations.
And then of course
there's the consideration
of your actual data format.
I think at this point both
libraries are reasonably clean,
but as Puneith mentioned,
going forward the
officially supported and
developed and promoted method
of working with TensorFlow will
be through Keras, especially
for the model authoring step
where you construct the model
structure.
So TensorFlow 1.9 just
came out a few days ago,
and it comes with a total
refresh of the TensorFlow
website in terms of the guides,
the Getting Started guides.
They are now all pivoted
to Keras and Eager mode,
which we didn't talk about here.
But we'll just skip that point.
Keras.
So basically Keras,
and more Keras.
Cool, yeah?
AUDIENCE: The data
[INAUDIBLE] mentioned, of this
is how we're get a clean
dataset, you have it.
But in real life
we get data, then
we get some more
data, [INAUDIBLE]..
YUFENG GUO: Yeah, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So in
a version control
we talk about [INAUDIBLE].
I mean that's just the code.
But at the end of the
model you went to what
data was used in the model.
A lot of these data signs were
[INAUDIBLE] for collaboration.
Are there, like, some of
these collaboration tools
within Google Cloud?
Or do you have any
recommendations for which ones
we should use?
[INAUDIBLE]
YUFENG GUO: Yeah,
so the question
is around the difficulties
behind versioning
datasets and collaboration
of training models
on differing versions
of those data,
as well as collaborating
on the source code itself--
which perhaps
software engineering
has developed more standards
around than for data.
So I'll throw a few
ideas around here.
One is that, in addition to the
Kaggle kernels being versioned,
the datasets are
actually also versioned.
So you can create new
versions of your dataset.
And when you combine
that with the notion
that you can have
private datasets that
are shared among a
selected group of users,
then you can fit together
a decent collaboration
model in that sense, because
you have version notebooks,
you have version datasets,
both with ability
to do access control.
That being said,
obviously Kaggle kernels
are not going to serve
all your production needs.
It's a great learning and
collaborative platform,
but when it comes time to deploy
your model-- when you're not
just competing in a
competition or doing something
for fun, then you
kind of end up having
to sometimes look elsewhere.
You mentioned CoLab
earlier today.
And so in CoLab
what's neat about it--
and I forgot to mention this in
the pro-con list by accident,
I assure you, because
it is a neat feature.
CoLab is like Jupyter
notebooks, Google Docs style.
And I mean that in its entirety.
In particular, it lets you
do simultaneous editing
just like in Google Docs.
So if I'm in the CoLab,
and you're in the CoLab,
we are both running against the
same computer in the back end.
It's like you and
I are sitting side
by side at the same machine,
but we for some reason
have two monitors and
the same file pulled up,
so we can look at different
parts at the same time.
And it means that
we can put comments
in, just like in Google Docs.
So you can actually add
comments to someone else's CoLab
and say, hey, I don't
think it is quite right.
Maybe you could try this thing.
Or you could use
it to ask questions
to your collaborators.
And so there's a lot of
different pieces there.
I don't know that
there's any good--
all the things combined
under the sun in one package
at this stage.
I'm sure folks are working
to make that happen and get
the advantages of
the different tools,
and kind of put them in a
more unified manner to A,
reduce confusion, but also
increase the functionality
and improve the
workflows around this.
So yeah, I mean that
kind of goes back
to the central
point around this,
that the tooling
is kind of still
in development, just across
the field in general.
There's new things happening all
the time, and for the most part
those new things are better.
Better things are coming and
they're coming at a rapid rate.
And it's an exciting
time, for sure.
Any other-- you want to add
anything to the tooling point?
PUNEITH KAUL: No to the tooling.
I just want to say that all
of these assets, the videos,
and code which was
shared will be available.
So check out our Google
AI Huddle channel.
Is that the right
term on Twitter?
Hashtag.
YUFENG GUO: Hashtag, hashtag.
PUNEITH KAUL: Not channel.
And you know, that's
where you basically
can watch for all announcements
and content and everything.
So we'll be doing that.
YUFENG GUO: So, raffle time?
PUNEITH KAUL: Sorry?
YUFENG GUO: Is it raffle time?
PUNEITH KAUL: I guess so,
unless there are more questions.
YUFENG GUO: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]